my name is Gloria Bai and I come from
Shanghai China currently I'm the Supply
Chain management student at MIT
s my name is Louisa and I'm from Brazil
I'm a master's student in Brazil I'm a
full-time student and my field of
research is in humanitarian Logistics
my name is Christian Bautista I'm coming
from the program in Spain originally
from Mexico and I've been I'm working in
the oil and gas industry for the last
six years beautiful my name is Amin I'm
from Tunisia I'm doing the master
program full-time as a program in
Malaysia and I have an engineering
background in Nano and biotechnology and
yeah
probably so so by way of introduction
you know I'm Kevin Smith and you you
know that I've been involved in supply
chain for the last 40 plus years
and got involved in supply chain
completely by accident
it was a full-time job for me working at
night unloading Freight cars when I was
going to college
and
I thought it would I would do that until
I found out what I really wanted to do
with my life and I guess I'm still
looking because because I've been
involved in it all of this time but it's
a wonderful career because it covers the
entire spectrum of the Enterprise
so I think you've all made wonderful
choices in terms of the direction you're
taking your careers but what questions
can I answer for you specifically for
sure
I want to ask you questions follow your
gesture introductions yeah for me my
experience also accidental is to yeah
working in Supply Chain management
because my major in my undergraduate
student school is Material Science and
Engineering but then I joined the
company for the procurement and right
now I really want to
persuade my career past especially focus
on Supply Chain management So based on
your experience I really want to know
could you please share your successful
stories and what's the qualification for
us to prepare to be a very good supply
chain candidate well that's a fantastic
question and first of all I'd say
just getting involved in some aspect of
supply chain so for instance procurement
is one major component of supply chain
today Supply chains and big companies
tend to go all the way from procuring
raw materials all the way through to the
consumer so if you're involved in one
part of supply chain there's no reason
you can't Branch out and and find other
parts of the supply chain that you'd be
interested in participating in the
beautiful part of it is that no matter
what part of supply chain you're
involved in you have an opportunity to
affect the bottom line
of the company that you're working with
so as you start in procurement you know
my advice would be look throughout the
supply chain look at transportation and
distribution and maybe even the
marketing aspects of supply chain to
figure out what are the other things
that I think I could make a positive
impact on based on what I know today
as you said we got involved in this by
accident
nobody woke up one day when they were a
teenager and said boy I really want to
be a supply chain manager that's not
just not the way it works we get
involved in businesses and then we find
out what we're good at and what we want
to participate in now I think that being
a supply chain manager is also an
excellent jumping off point to the
c-suite CFO coo CEO of a company because
once you've understood what happens
throughout the entire company
from procurement all the way through the
consumer you've got a much better idea
of what the Enterprise is going to do
you're welcome
so my question is of course about the
military logistics so I I think I saw
something about the Red Cross and and
you no yeah okay so so my question is
actually if you feel that
um
or how you feel that non-oriented
humanitarian companies like just regular
business companies can help the
humanitarian sector
and providing better response to
disasters okay well you know if in terms
of providing humanitarian efforts or
just being involved socially many
companies making a real effort to do
this they want to be socially
responsible they want to participate so
for instance I was the chairman of the
Red Cross for Rhode Island for the State
of Rhode Island while I was working at
CVS now CBS supported that because you
know we were major player in the
community there was no reason for us not
to now it's a personal decision of
course if you individuals have to want
to do this they have to want to get
involved in humanitarian efforts I
personally deal with a lot of
non-profits today and this is when I
retired from full-time corporate work
this gave me an opportunity to do a lot
of things that I wanted to do so I've
worked with the Red Cross I've worked
with Alan which is the American
Logistics Aid Network part of cscmp is
spawned off of csemp so we're doing a
lot of work with Haiti for instance
after the earthquake we're coming up on
the fifth anniversary of fourth
anniversary of the earthquake now in
Haiti still a lot of work to be done
most companies want to be socially
responsible they want to have a presence
in organizations like the Red Cross as
an individual I think it's up to you
though to go to your your manager your
supervisor the CEO and say would it be
okay if I participated in this as a
representative of our company
but I think it's a wonderful thing to do
but it's a very personal decision and by
the way it takes a lot of time
yeah
thank you you're welcome oh I think that
makes so um I am a member of the Apex so
one of your partnership competitors it's
one for everybody
so and so far I mean I got certification
from from them and I still I don't I
just feel that they are kind of behind
in terms of education and I don't know
how your organization is trying to come
up or try to update those online courses
online training and and if in the future
you're looking for some alliances with I
don't know if you know about Khan
Academy this alongside that you can get
education I'm not familiar with them
okay so well well some sort of education
online so as you plan to maybe look for
Elias and in order to expand your
organization in terms of online
well you know one of the major
items of Interest I think among supply
chain managers especially emerging
supply chain managers is how can I
demonstrate to my company how can I
demonstrate to other people that I'm
proficient at what I do so Apex for
years has had their certification
program which is aimed primarily at
inventory now I'm going to put in a
Shameless plug here for cscmp because as
the chair elect for cscmp I can tell you
we've developed a
a program for certification which is in
three elements a basic certification
a more extensive certification and a
more of a case study certification
program and we're we're actually really
welcoming people who've been involved in
Apex because inventory is a major
component of what you do in supply chain
but there's so much more as we discussed
before and from procurement all the way
through the consumer there's so much
more to learn so we've actually put
together a certification program which
is based on an eight book series we've
published eight books that cover all the
primary aspects of supply chain and then
we ask people to take the certification
test and you know see if they actually
are proficient I think it's a great
thing you know whether it's cscmp or
somebody else that does it I think it's
a great way for people in the industry
to demonstrate to their companies that
they actually know what they're doing
because you know let's face it most CEOs
don't understand supply chain most CFOs
don't understand supply chain so if you
can say I'm certified and by
certification that means that I've taken
a course of study and I've taken the
test and this organization this major
organization really understands supply
chain has said I know this stuff I think
that's a good thing
now I'll also say this as you're going
through this process make friends with
the CFO make friends with the CEO and by
that I don't mean uh you know just you
know suck up to them I mean demonstrate
to them the value that you bring to the
company demonstrate to them the things
that you can do that affect the bottom
line and therefore give them a boost on
the top line to the company and
certification is one of those things
though that really demonstrates that you
know what you're doing so I'd encourage
you to continue that and I encourage you
to get with cscmp and get certification
thank you
my question is we have on the supply
chain business we have for many
components of the supply chain we have
different metrics for the tour to assess
our performance do we have a performance
metric for the whole supply chain I mean
some metrics like that can gives us more
insight on what's going on on the whole
supply chain from the supplier or
material until the end the consumer so I
think it's one part it's really
difficult to assess to for the hard
supply chain so what do you think about
it according to your experience of
course you know what I'm happy to talk
about this because it's something I'm
I'm very passionate about
when it comes to metrics I think that
historically we've tried to measure too
much
so when when you start to do a metrics
program first of all it has to be very
specific
not to if you try to measure everything
in the whole supply chain you're going
to get overwhelmed so the metrics have
to really focus on the things that
really drive your business and more
likely than not they're probably going
to be things that are specific to a
particular supplier partner or you know
relationship
and I would say I tell those people all
the time pick five or six things that
you really think are important and focus
on those now if your partners are
consumer goods manufacturers and you're
a retailer those metrics those five or
six might be different for each one of
your partners slightly different some
things are always going to be the same
do you deliver on time do you you know
do you deliver complete orders those are
things that are generally important
but I'll tell you in the past I've been
involved both in my manufacturing life
and in the retail life where we had just
too many metrics you know at one point I
remember sitting down with our partners
and we had a standard metrics program
for all suppliers there were 70 things
we were measuring 70. it was too much it
would take a half a day to get through
it and at the end you'd say did we
actually move the business forward or
did we just find a new way to punish our
supplier so metrics should not be used
for punishment they should be used to
help you drive your business to higher
levels pick five or six things and focus
on those and it makes it difficult to
make a decision if you have too many
metrics and so when you get lost you get
lost in the data and once you start to
get lost in the data you lose sight of
what's really important so you know you
if you're in a business what you want to
do is you want to control costs you want
to boost profits you want to improve
your margin so what are the five or six
things you can measure with a particular
partner that help you do those things
whether you're a supplier or a retailer
or a wholesale it doesn't really matter
what are the five or six things that are
really important do you think there is a
quote for an Einstein that says not
everything that anything that matters
can become another thing that management
matters Albert Einstein yes not
everything that comes can be counted not
everything that can be counted counts
he's my hero and I actually I have that
slide in almost every presentation I
made I'm glad you brought it up
great okay
um I have another questions follow my
previous ones I really love your answer
and it's based on my experience
um after seven or more than seven years
working experience I realized okay I
really love the supply chain so that's
why I apply for this program but I also
realized what my weakness
um based on the previous experience for
example is two Narrows in just one area
of the home supply chain and I lack of
the quantitative analysis skills at Lake
House end-to-end understanding knowledge
of the supply chain so that's why I come
here to learn more knowledge and skill
sets however so at that time at the
beginning I also think okay my future
career goal maybe can expound and jump
out of the box maybe not just the focus
on the procurement also can think about
the planning the forecasting and even
the logistic inventory however in the
real world I realized that if I want to
to change or switch my career it's not
easy because companies always want to
make them make the profit and focus on
the margin So currently I really have
sometimes too confusing my career ago
how can I to prepare for the future
career and I really want to expound my
career instead of just to focus on the
procurement yeah so what's your
suggestions first of all you're getting
yourself a fantastic education which is
much broader than your current
experience so that that so you have to
advertise that and by advertising I mean
you need to talk to your supervisor your
manager your company and tell them what
you want to do now this sounds easy I'm
going to tell you
when I was running big companies
I loved it when somebody came to me and
said you know I'm in procurement but I'd
really like to understand how the
distribution system works I'd say that's
fantastic we can make that happen let's
make it part of your development plan to
do that you know we could put you there
for six months or we can make a complete
change and you can work for distribution
for a year or two and you know we'll
then we'll see if that's what you want
to do or if there are other things you
want to do I think it only helps a
company to have people come forward and
say I want to do more I want to
understand more I want to contribute
more to the to the Enterprise and people
who stay in their little Silo of
understanding the people who who first
of all I guess I'm being mean there's
nothing wrong with that if somebody
wants to be a procurement manager for
their entire career I guess that's okay
it wouldn't have worked for me I you
know I wouldn't have wanted to do that I
wanted to know more I wanted to
experience more I wanted to control more
maybe control is the real issue but uh
just talk to them and tell them that you
have an interest expanding what you do I
would be shocked if they said oh no you
have to stay in procurement forever
any good manager is going to say let's
make that part of your development plan
and let's make sure that you get
exposure to that and by the way you
might find out you don't like it you
might find out that procurement is
really where you want to be yeah you're
right and I also need to choose a good
company can give me this development
opportunities well and that's true and
you know this is a good point for
everybody
when you're interviewing for a job with
a company interview the company as well
because this goes for not just for
supply chain if you get up in the
morning and you say oh good it's time to
go to work that's a good thing if you
get up in the morning say oh God it's
time to go to work that's a bad thing
you have to find something that you're
happy doing in order to be really
successful you'll never be the best
person you can be if you don't enjoy
what you do I never had a day
when I went to work and I said boy I
really hate this I got I got to a point
where I said there are other things I
want to do and therefore I'm going to
retire and because I wanted to do more
work with non-profits I wanted to do you
know work with organizations that were
trying to improve either Supply chains
to remote parts of the world or or help
the Red Cross locally that those are all
good things but when you're in a company
be the best you can possibly be and if
you don't enjoy what you're doing find
something else to do
thank you you're welcome
well so I think I'm going to follow
Gloria's line in this
because
um my I'm in for undergrad school I did
Civil Engineering so I'm a civil
engineer and I was working with
structural design and I was designing
ports and when I
would look at a port that would say God
this layout is so more so more
interesting than what I am doing so I
got interested in logistics because of
that and I decided to go back to the
university and pursue a master's degree
that that has to do with Logistics so
now I'm at this point that I'm finishing
my masters but I don't really know
where to start you know what company
what kind of company should start and I
wanted to be in a company that actually
gives me opportunities like you
mentioned to see every part of of the
chain kind of get to know every little
part of it but
um
I think my question is
what suggestion did you give to me
on how to look for a company how to how
to
where should I start you know
first of all I'd say you first you've
already really narrowed the field
because you want to be involved in
logistics and supply chain that's great
I'll tell you this I never knew
throughout my career I don't think what
my next job was going to be and when I
did know what my next job was going to
be
sometimes I didn't care for that and I
tried to steer away from it that's one
of the reasons that I left Kraft I was
with General foods and craft for 25
years I knew what my next job was going
to be and I didn't want to do that
I had already I had already tasted the
bigger scope of logistics building
networks and that's that's what I wanted
to do so I mean I think I was in a
similar position to you
if you don't know what you want to do
long term it doesn't really matter
what company you get involved with as
long as you get involved with a company
that you feel comfortable with and
you'll know when you interview with a
company you'll get a feel for you know
whether or not there's a mental match
and whether you're comfortable there and
if you're not comfortable don't do it
you know even if they offer you a huge
amount of money don't do it because
money is not going to make you happy in
the long run in the long run you're
going to be happy if you're doing things
that you really enjoy with people that
you enjoy so check out the company first
you can look online a lot of times you
can look at the annual reports for most
of these companies and get a feel for
what it is they do if you're
uncomfortable with it move on to
something else
the other thing you could do is you
could talk to people either in the
company or in the industry this is where
organizations like cscmp I think become
very valuable because if you remember
cscmp we could connect you with people
probably in that company or in companies
that deal with that company and you can
get a feel for whether or not it's
someplace that people are comfortable or
whether they feel threatened or you know
some companies you just don't want to
work for and it's much better to find
that out before you go there than after
you go there
so I think you're on the right track and
by the way I was an English major right
so so I had no idea what I wanted to do
is I wanted to teach in the public
school system
but I was making 4.63 cents an hour and
a union job unloading Freight cars at
night
that's about ten thousand dollars a year
that's what I was going to make as a
public school teacher ten thousand
dollars that just tells you how old I am
right so uh although they probably don't
make much more than that today when I I
got an offer to become a foreman in the
warehouse for fourteen thousand dollars
well that was a forty percent raise in
pay right there and that was what
encouraged me to stay and then from
there on I just I got opportunities to
try different jobs the companies that I
was with the Louisa were wonderful I
enjoyed the companies I enjoyed the
people and the day that you don't enjoy
it then you have to start thinking about
what am I going to do next where do I
want to go next
you're welcome
Kevin um the next one I'm gonna say with
the with the organization you're
currently with my my question is going
to be what is the worldwide expansion so
do you have any plans I mean like you
try to go for it if more countries I
mean I know it's online it's a csmp
again you're asking about well we're
actually already a global organization
we have uh we have round tables in
oh gosh I should know this off the top
of my head I don't know we have about
104 round tables right now around the
world the majority of them are in the us
but we have a number of roundtables in
Europe India uh Africa
Australia so uh South America so there
are round tables all around the world
right now we should make them more
robust and the other thing that we
really need to do is make sure the
people are participating in the round
tables become members of cscmp because
that's how they get the most benefit out
of participating so it's one thing to go
to a round table once and hear a message
if you get something good out of that if
you enjoy it then that should encourage
you to become a member of that
organization and
get more of the message have more access
to the education to the information
that's available but it's already a
global organization we have run
conferences we run the annual Global
conferences always in the U.S but we
have run conferences in Europe Asia
in the past it's hard it's hard for us
to do
when you expand
to Europe
you know that the EU
is the EU in name only right I mean it's
it's really 40 plus countries who all
want to act completely independently but
they have a common currency
it's very difficult to create a kind of
a an EU conference where you attract
everybody if we go to Germany we attract
Germans and maybe you know maybe some
people from the Netherlands if we go to
France we get French people yeah but and
maybe somebody from Luxembourg you know
Benelux but uh
it's it's become more difficult for us
to do Europe but we're working hard to
figure out how we create that value
proposition so that people want to
participate and we'll probably try to
expand more over time into Europe but we
are a global organization today and you
can take advantage of the all the global
activities that go on yeah that's going
to be my next question I mean how do you
customize or tailor the problems for
each region of the world but I mean you
already got it uh how do we cover it
yeah no no I mean you're already you're
already answered my question because I
was going to ask that yeah very good I'd
like to pre-answer the question so as we
say we save time that way
yeah my question is um
I don't during during the whole career
for example for internet store when you
manage it when you have to manage stores
for CVS for example at what time
um
because now with the internet of things
with all the data Big Data everything so
I think I guess one logical thing to do
for any business is to think about
e-commerce
and so my question is
um
if you have to think about it and you
have to apply it how what makes the
what drives your decision to move to
e-commerce and apply it in a real in the
real business okay first of all I want
to clarify I didn't run the stores I ran
the operations that went up to the
stores okay so uh because I don't want
some store managers to come back and
yell at me saying that I took his job
away but your question is a wonderful
question in today's environment because
it's not just e-commerce it's Omni
channel right I mean everybody wants to
get their product everywhere they want
to get it online they want to get it in
store traditional brick and mortar they
want to they might have every
opportunity every different opportunity
to get product now some people like to
go to a store and pick things up and
feel they're very tactile they say well
this is what I want to buy other people
might say I don't care some people like
to go to the store the first time for
instance if you know if you like a
particular kind of blouse from a
particular manufacturer you'd want to go
to the store the first time say well
this is really what I like it fits well
now I can buy them online I don't have
to go back to the store okay that's all
right too so Omni channel the idea that
everybody that sells stuff has to come
up with a way to service all of their
customers either in a store environment
online or some other way
you know direct to Consumer these are
these are all things that every company
has to consider so at CVS we had a very
active e-commerce business so and it's
uh
it's not a matter of do you want to do
it you have to do it because you risk
losing customers
ultimately we're going to see a lot of
change in the way this happens exactly
the impact on the supply chain yeah um
are you familiar with Tesco the the
British retailer well in
Korea they've instituted a new program
in the subway system
which is incredible they've put pictures
of the products on the wall in the
subway stations with the with the with
the barcode people get off the subway
they use their smartphone to take a
picture of the product that they want
upload it and the product gets delivered
to their home I mean this is an
incredible idea for omnichannel because
now you've got people who are very busy
you know they're working long days or
they don't have time to shop this is
giving them another channel it's a very
unique Channel there's another there's a
retailer in the UK called John Lewis who
is taking home delivery and last mile
delivery to a new level they've took the
idea a couple of years ago working with
a company called Descartes
systems and they said do our customers
really want next day delivery because
this is what everybody thinks everybody
wants next day delivery what do they
want convenient delivery and so what
they did was they they created a program
where they'd say to their customer okay
we understand you want it when do you
want it they say next day they say do
you really want it next day or is there
a time this week that you'd really like
to have it they said well Thursday
afternoon at three o'clock would really
be perfect because that's when I get
home from work or I pick up the kids
from school so they said fine so they've
created a program where they're now able
to instead of doing this hurry hurry
hurry next day delivery plan deliveries
which means that first of all we haven't
talked about sustainability but it makes
them more sustainable because they can
get better utilization of their trucks
but it also allows them to not have to
go to that very expensive
emergency shipment plan they can plan
their shipments and I think this is
going to be the wave of the future
everybody thinks right now that it's got
to be next day or same day that's not
necessarily true if I'm buying something
it's very rare that I need it today if I
need it today I'm probably going to go
to the store but if I need it
tomorrow do I really need it tomorrow or
do I need it a couple of days from now
and it makes it much more affordable for
everybody last year here in the U.S
we had a situation at Christmas time
with FedEx and UPS where a lot of the
online retailers were saying buy it
Monday and you'll have it by Tuesday for
in time for Christmas when the whole
system almost collapsed so you're
familiar with this I'm sure it's been a
case study you've used and at that point
this was the canary in the coal mine if
you will this was a warning shot for us
to understand how this business is going
to continue to go this year they did a
much better job with it and the way they
did a better job with it I believe is
UPS and FedEx and DHL went to their
retailers and they said we can't do this
again it's it's going to hurt your
business it's going to hurt our business
so don't be promising free next day
delivery with a one-day window and they
didn't and everything went much smoother
so these are the things we learn these
are the things the supply chain is
responsible for and while the the normal
citizen the person who's not involved in
supply chain
all they knew was they were mad last
year because they didn't get their
product in time for Christmas
this year they didn't notice so
congratulations to all of us for doing a
good job of fixing that we may never get
the credit for it but it's what we do
so basically the what is the main impact
I mean on applying the e-commerce main
impact on the supply chain I mean you
have the logistics part to manage the
delivery part okay the main impact yeah
the main number okay so the biggest
thing you have to consider is how am I
going to do this so Omni channel is a
fine is a great term
but what you have to remember is
everything has to ship from some place
it doesn't ship from the ethernet it has
to ship physically from someplace so
people who are involved in a
multi-channel delivery multi-channel
businesses have to figure out how am I
going to handle that so am I going to
house the product that I put in my brick
and mortar stores in the same
Distribution Center as my e-commerce or
am I going to set up a completely
different facility am I going to
Outsource that business to someone else
these these are all questions that you
have to answer for yourself and again I
would say that the Supply Chain
management professionals play a huge
role in this it's not just marketing
because the Supply Chain management
professionals have to figure out where
does that inventory need to be how much
do we have to have and you know what's
the safety stock that's involved so all
the things we talked about you know you
need a forecast and e-commerce
especially there's absolutely no way to
forecast e-commerce anybody can sit down
at a computer any time of the day and
say
I want that it's it's much easier to
predict your sales in a store where you
open at nine o'clock in the morning you
close at nine o'clock at night because
you can over time you can predict how
many people are going to come in
e-commerce very hard so what's your
inventory situation going to be and are
you going to keep it all in one building
or are you going to split it up into the
different channels personally I'm a
proponent of keeping it all in one
building because I think there's an
opportunity to share inventory there
that you don't have if you split it into
different buildings
thank you because today's market is
really amazing it's not only for the
Innovations Market but also the
Integrations Market okay yeah so I also
very yeah I feel very excited for the
future because as you said it's really a
merch Channel and I also heard that they
have a lot of new technology to make our
dreams to come true for example like you
said we can share in the inventory even
I heard some projects in China happened
as they try to put some inventory from
the big retail company to the
supermarket near the community and
people as a community persons they can
pick up their
shopping things from the supermarkets so
the network is really sharing currently
it's amazing so this is the beautiful
thing about supply chain is it always
changes
and we're the people that have to figure
out how that change is going to affect
the businesses that we work for so again
I applaud you for selecting this as your
career I don't think you'll be
disappointed I think it can be very
rewarding both mentally and financially
and I'll look forward to working with
all of you in the future thanks very
much thank you very much thank you thank
you thank you thank you so much